with tomorrow's vote on next generation
eu
you are writing history it is worth just
for a moment to pause and look at the
big picture here
i say that because next generation you
can lead
to the most ambitious overhaul of the
european economy in
decades but any recovery starts with
overcoming this virus
the commission has negotiated the
broadest portfolio
of vaccine candidates and finally within
a week
the first vaccine will be authorized
so that vaccinations can start
immediately
and more will follow in the new year and
in total
we have bought more than enough doses
for everyone in europe
and we will be able to support our
neighbors
and our partners around the world
through covax
so that no one is left behind
but to get to the end of the pandemic
we will need up to 70 percent of the
population vaccinated this is a
huge task a big task so
let's start as soon as possible with a
vaccination
together as 27
with the start at the same day as
we've gone in unity through this
pandemic
let's start the eradication of this
horrible virus
together and united
you